Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this is
going to be my new marvel mcu ghost Rider
video there was some recent announcements about
what's going on with the project they actually
just put up some casting listings so i'll explain
what's going on there's a bunch of easter eggs we
know a little bit about what's happening with the
darker side of the mcu going into marvel phase 4.
if you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the marvel videos we're
doing a giveaway for the new spider-man miles
morales playstation 5 game all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and post all your mcu
Ghost Rider theories on the video so just starting
with the big stuff first recently an official
talent grid for marvel's new ghost rider project
officially went up on a legit production website
apparently we're not allowed to screen cap those
or we'll get sued i'm not sure who's going to sue
us disney marvel or the production websites but
those sites are for movie and tv industry insiders
letting everyone know that works on those projects
when there's work to be had when they're casting
when they're filming so that everyone who wants
to work on those projects knows when to apply
for positions or submit actors the information
doesn't say whether it's a marvel phase 5 movie
like the new blade movie or a disney plus series
like moon knight with oscar isaac can't wait to
see what that's going to look like but recently
deadline variety hollywood reporter the rap all
the major hollywood trade publications posted
features on the changes going on behind the scenes
at disney this year as you would expect because
2020 has been such a crap year for everyone
including mega companies with infinite money
like disney they've accelerated their transition
to what you would call a direct consumer model of
their business the way the disney ceo talked about
it the last couple of months is that the majority
of their focus is on developing stuff for disney
plus de-prioritizing traditional tv shows and also
kind of theatrical releases they're always going
to release their bigger marvel movies in theaters
like the black widow movie is currently coming out
in may they're still going to release that in may
but you wait and watch they're going to drop
that video on demand so quickly after they
drop it in theaters the way they release things is
going to look a little bit different in the next
couple of years that's why i think the title
for this new project which is just listed as
marvel's ghost rider just implies that they're
intending it to be a disney plus series alongside
moon knight in a couple years you'll also be
surprised to hear that a lot of the trades were
reporting that most of kevin feige's attention
right now is actually on the disney plus series
more so than he's focusing on the marvel movies
what you would call the machinery behind the
scenes for them making their big marvel phase
4 phase 5 movies even the big avengers movies
it's well established this giant support
structure is clear timelines for everything
it's much easier for them to get the movies
out now than the disney plus series so kevin
feige is still kind of figuring that out right
now but number four most of you will remember
this is not the first time that marvel has tried
to do a ghost rider tv show recently you may have
all seen the hellstrom marvel series on hulu even
though they took a lot of the marvel branding off
of it it is a marvel show it is a marvel character
the episodes are up right now i just did a video
for the ending so i'll link it in the description
but they kind of canceled it after the first
season was done like they aren't continuing with
the show it's a one season show originally it was
intended to set off a midnight sun's hearts of
darkness style ghost rider universe of crossover
shows like a new version of the marvel netflix
series but on hulu because disney owns hulu now
originally marvel had intended to put all their
darker r-rated hardcore stuff that they gotten
in the fox purchase like the deadpool movies
on hulu because disney plus was supposed to be
firmly pg-13 now they're actually talking about
building a special section of disney plus that's
locked with adult passwords so that children can't
get into them so they can have the children's side
of disney plus for all the younger programming
but they can also put all their deadpool r-rated
stuff on there too so number three the new ghost
rider universe of shows would have originally been
led by gabriel luna's version of ghost rider
from agents of shield that would have been a
big spin-off series for him robbie reyes that's
because the people who were making the ghost
rider series were the same people who made agents
of shield jeff loeb the marvel tv people who all
pretty much recently just got fired from marvel
that was because disney gave control of everything
marvel to kevin feige so now feige controls all
the movies like you would expect all the tv shows
but he also controls all of marvel comics as well
previously the marvel studios people kevin feige's
team only did the movies the exception to that
was the agent carter tv series with haley atwell
they actually produced that themselves kevin
feige himself even did some of the editing
on that tv show the marvel tv people jeff loeb's
team did pretty much all the other tv shows though
agents of shield they were also responsible for
the inhumans tv show which we shall never speak
of again but they also did the marvel netflix
series some of them were actually pretty solid
like daredevil luke cage jessica jones punisher
and yes they were to blame for netflix iron fist
the new reports are saying now that this new
version of Ghost Rider that marvel is doing
will not be gabriel luna's version they're going
to recast it'll be johnny blaze and with the
exception of the multiverse doctor strange 2 in
the concept that everything is canon technically
through the multiverse the new ghost rider project
will be a full reboot in the mcu he'll be the main
mcu version of ghost rider and they'll treat
it like the nicholas cage ghost rider movies
happened in another universe but obviously there's
always the opportunity for nicolas cage cameos
i haven't seen any legit casting rumors as to who
they're looking at right now i know everyone's
top picks are norman reedus or keanu reeves i see
those names on every single video i've done in the
past few years that even mentions mcu Ghost Rider
kevin feige actually has some funny comments about
keanu reeves in the mcu last year there was a
leak last year that keanu reeves had gone to
meet with marvel about a marvel phase 4 or marvel
phase 5 project so everybody wondered what it was
what role what character he be playing after the
fact journalists got kevin feige in interviews and
he just said that the truth of the matter was is
that they had been talking to keanu reeves about
playing a marvel character since way back in the
days of the first avengers movie marvel phase one
that's almost 10 years ago the way he talked about
it the reason why kiana reeves has not been in a
marvel movie before was just because they hadn't
found the right character for him to play yet so
you think about all the big marvel characters
we've had so far and try to imagine kiana ryu
is playing them and you're like okay i can kind
of see how keanu reeves wouldn't want to play xyz
characters that happens all the time like matthew
mcconaughey was up for a big mcu role a couple
years ago and passed on it when actors are that
powerful and they have that much money they don't
need the extra check from disney they usually wind
up passing if they don't completely identify or
jive with a character keanu reeves is a motorcycle
fanatic if you didn't know he actually owns his
own motorcycle shop that does a lot of customs
they're actually pretty fantastic so if you live
in the los angeles area and you ever caught him
riding around town on his motorcycles that's why
but if by some miracle the keanu reeves did wind
up playing mcu ghost rider it's a bit of a long
shot they would probably then try to turn the
new ghost rider project into a movie i think
it a lot of it just depends on which actor
they get like oscar isaac is playing moon
knight he's a huge actor but moon knight is such
a weird character that's why they're doing it as
a disney plus series and then oscar isaac moon
knight is going to cross over into the movies
even if a brand new character debuts in a disney
plus series they're still technically viewed as a
movie character because all the disney plus series
are influencing the plots of the marvel phase 4
marvel phase 5 movies and the characters will
cross over into them for those of you that are
big fans of norman reedus too the problem with
norman reedus Ghost Rider is that he actually
wouldn't have time to do a marvel series or even
a movie because he just signed a new deal with the
walking dead people for a daryl and carol spin-off
series from the main show once that ends next year
but number one most likely scenario just
based on the way their new disney plus shows
are coming together and darker mcu stuff the
new ghost rider project is probably going to
be part of their larger midnight suns hearts
of darkness crossover plan with the new blade
movies and the new moon knight series and any
other darker disney plus series that they do
kevin feige said that they were always looking for
a way into the darker supernatural mcu characters
like blade is going to introduce vampires into the
mcu and doctor strange has been the key to that
they had to wait till after they did the first
doctor strange movie before they could start doing
the really crazy or supernatural characters right
now they're actually getting ready to film doctor
strange 2 in the next couple of weeks elizabeth
olsen was just talking about that scarlet witch
herself she just finished the wanda vision
series now she's heading over to england to film
the movie with benedict cumberbatch because she's
one of the main characters we're going to get all
those Wandavision episodes in january of course
i'll be doing videos for all those episodes but
that's going to directly set up the plot of doctor
strange 2 with its multiverse arc but doctor
strange 2 is going to get even crazier with that
because it's coming after a bunch of other marvel
phase 4 movies that's why everyone's talking
about spider-verse easter eggs in spider-man 3
live-action spider-verse easter eggs they're also
filming spider-man 3 with tom holland right now
and doctor strange is a main character in that
movie along with jamie foxx's electro from the
andrew garfield amazing spider-man movies i do
have a new spider-man 3 video and an mcu daredevil
video that i'm working on i should be able to
post those pretty soon but just let me know in
the comments who you want the new mcu Ghost Rider
to be and who you want him to cross over with
i'll also be posting my full mandalorian season 2
episode 5 video on friday just like normal so as
long as you have alerts enabled for my channel
you should see all those videos when they post
big shout out to daniel richmond for giving me the
new Ghost Rider production info for my video he
actually has a patreon where he does a lot of
scoops so if you're really into that stuff he
actually does that on the side congratulations
los malone you're the winner of the spiderman
miles morales playstation game giveaway from my
last big marvel video please contact me on the
about page of my channel so i can get your details
everyone click here for my new mandalorian season
2 ahsoka tano video and click here to learn
about the big thor 4 avengers 5 announcement
thank you so much for watching happy
thanksgiving everyone i'll see you guys tonight!